Mass Effect 1 is the start of a
fantastic series its job is to make sure
the player knows about the world and its
inhabitants but also make sure they even
care about that stuff to begin with
thankfully Mass Effect 1 has not only
some of the best world building I've
seen in a video game to date when it
comes to its races and backstories but
also sets up the main threat of the game
to be more than what it seems it gives
the player a chance to marinate in all
the side quests and characters before
letting him know that their entire world
is about to crumble before their very
eyes and I'm getting too far ahead of
myself so allow me to explain what Mass
Effect is about and how incredible its
story truly is
let's get started Mass Effect is a
science fiction RPG that takes place in
the Milky Way galaxy and Humanity in
this universe has expanded far past our
current capabilities not only has
Humanity been able to travel and
colonize planets within our current
solar system but we've been able to go
to numerous places across the Milky Way
at the edge of the solar system near
Pluto is a mass relay an old Relic from
an ancient civilization that has given
Humanity the means to see the outer
reaches of the Galaxy but we aren't the
only ones to have found these relays in
fact were actually late to the party
like 2 000 years late we play as
Commander Shepard a soldier aboard the
Normandy Airship and A Tear where our
Story begins since Mass Effect is a
role-playing game it's only natural that
the first thing we do is create our
character's look and background
admittedly though I have never been a
fan of how BioWare handled these
backgrounds for this game because
they're pretty meaningless you can
choose between three types of personal
service history and three types of
psychological profiles the former comes
with a unique Mission and the latter has
some unique dialogue and another mission
it's not terrible but it's just hard to
feel like choices matter when all we get
is a different dialogue in the intro
afterward we'll get a brief Montage of
the ship and the mass relay Mass Effect
has always been about spectacle and
cinematic presentation having a sense of
wonder is at the core of Science Fiction
so getting the player to believe that
they are in the far future is key and
the intro does this in a few ways by not
only showing us images of advanced
technology but also alien species I am
going to hold off on discussing the
other aliens of mass effect until a bit
later though from here the player could
explore the ship and talk with the crew
and during this downtime Israel notice
the dialogue system and something called
Paragon and Renegade Mass Effect opted
for a dialogue wheel to match their
voice protagonist the alternative of
course is having a silent protagonist
but a full description of dialogue
personally I prefer the latter only
because I like to know what I'm saying
such as in this example where I'm asking
Liara if she's okay but the actual
dialogue says that Dr shakwa should take
a look at her I only picked that option
because I wanted my character to ask if
she was okay considering I'm sort of
responsible for causing her headaches
but the game didn't allow me to this is
just one example but there are dozens of
other instances in which this has
happened and if you've played a game
with a dialogue wheel then you
understand what I mean as for the
Paragon and Renegade these represent
Mass effect's Karma systems Paragon
points are given for good actions and
Renegade for bad ones this allows the
player to role play a specific way or at
the very least give them a way to track
their current characters actions using
the bars located in the menu I ended up
going through the game twice with one
focusing on Paragon and the other
focusing on Renegade so we can see the
different outcomes as we play but also
see how the game evolves over time
because of our actions the hope is that
there will be enough choices to make the
playthrough feel different allowing
players to have a unique experience
their first time through picking up
where we left off Shepard here is tasked
with going to a place called Eden Prime
and doing a covert pickup he'll be
accompanied by nihilus atturian and also
a specter Specter served the galactic
Council a group of people will meet in a
few minutes and nilas here not only
wants to make sure the mission goes
smoothly but also wants to assess
Shepard as he is on the candidacy list
for becoming a specter and if he
succeeds that would make Shepard the
first human Specter in the Galaxy one
thing I love about science fiction is
the ability to change the food chain on
Earth humans are the apex predators but
in space we might not be as strong as we
think and humanity and Mass Effect is
just like that humans only recently
became a part of the galactic Community
it's only been about 40 years since
Humanity found a mass relay while
orbiting Pluto whereas the turgans have
been involved with the other races for
over thousands of years now so humanity
is way behind in terms of Galactic
Evolution I love the way this was
handled in Mass Effect as this has an
impact on the story as many of the
people from various races look down upon
humans as they deem them as lesser
beings such as sarin another Tyrion and
another Specter he doesn't like humans
much given the war between the humans
and turgans that started shortly after
meeting each other for the first time
and this Prejudice has stayed with him
for a very long time but he doesn't just
seem to hate humans apparently he just
dislikes people in general as he kills
his fellow friend nilas for no apparent
reason this act will kick off the main
plot of the story sarin was searching
for the beacon the same item we plan to
take back to the council as it will help
him find something called the conduit he
also Enlisted the help of the Geth a
group of beings that haven't been seen
outside their home Colony for over 200
years so already things aren't adding up
we have a specter going rogue a race of
beings known as seen in over two
centuries and to make things worse the
object Shepard was tasked with finding
is a lot more important than it may seem
s
[Music]
this Beacon was created by a race of
beings called the protheans the
prothians were in ancient civilization
that went extinct over 50 000 years ago
but no one knows why the one thing that
remains of them is some of their
technology like the mass relays seren
clearly knew about the device and its
location which means he knows something
and we need to figure out what that is
but we have more diplomatic problems at
hand nihilus is dead and the beacon is
destroyed the console is clearly not
going to be happy with this result
especially since this was supposed to be
a test for Shepard after a thorough
investigation the council seems to have
found no evidence that reinforces our
claim that Sharon has committed treason
all hope is not lost though the only
lead we have is a Terrian called Garrus
that was the head of an investigation
against Aaron so we'll need to find him
and see if he knows anything during this
Mission we'll also come across a Kroger
named Rex and Aquarian named Tali these
three end up becoming a part of our new
crew and our three of the six companions
we can take on missions these missions
involving these three have you traveling
quite a bit throughout the Citadel as
the game starts to open up a bit and
it's quite obvious to tell from the
gameplay that this place is stunning the
Brazilian level of the Citadel is one of
the most stunning places in this game
even though we are playing on the
legendary edition the original back in
2007 was still a sight to behold just
like I mentioned before science fiction
is all about creating these unique
buildings and planets so you can be
convinced that what you're seeing is
truly from the future and mass effect
does this in Spades but it's not just
the planetary and environmental design
that will be used as a showcase for the
vision of the future it's also the alien
species the beginning missions here on
the Citadel do a wonderful job of
fleshing out the world and giving the
player a chance to see some of the
Game's new species and despite the
criticism this series will eventually
get over the coming years the races have
never been in this discussion Mass
Effect has some of the best world
building I have ever seen when it comes
to alien species all these races are so
uniquely designed that once you see what
a specific race looks like it will never
leave your mind but not only are the
designs unique but their histories are
too each race has unique backgrounds
that cover anything from Anatomy to
government to beliefs everything about
them is so distinctive that it's hard to
find any similarities between each race
to understand what I mean though allow
me to take some time to go over the
races we meet in game the first race we
should probably talk about is our own
the humans of Mass Effect are not that
different from us in the real world but
the reason I wanted to mention them is
because of their first contact with new
life since the traversable world has now
expanded for Humanity everyone was quick
to find and colonize new planets this
however ticked off the galactic Council
something the humans had no clue even
existed at this point Humanity attempted
to reactivate a dormant Mass relay which
under Council law is illegal the group
is then shot down by turians which then
started a conflict between humans and
the turians it ended pretty quickly as
the turians underestimated Humanity's
strength and the council was quick to
broker peace between everyone soon after
they would then be invited to join the
other races on the Citadel and the rest
is what we see in game humans populate
the Citadel and are frequently seen on
other planets researching and colonizing
any place they can go but despite their
best efforts they've not been fully
recognized by the council this leads to
our next race the turians they are one
of three console races here in Mass
Effect they were invited to the Council
of over 1200 years ago and are seen as
the galactic peacekeepers due to this
role they also have the largest military
presence in the galaxy and while they
may not be known for their strength or
skill like some of the races are they
are definitely well known for their
discipline most of what is known or
respected about the terrygans comes down
to their military prowess but there is
information about the other parts of
their lives too turians can be religious
but are not forced to believe in any
specific deity or God most of the turian
belief centers around individual
responsibility meaning there are no good
or evil deities that can encourage or
discourage certain behaviors they do
however believe places and groups have
spirits that represent them so a group
of soldiers could have a spirit that
shows honor and courage and something
like a city or landscape can reflect
success and Beauty they don't believe
that these Spirits are evil or affect
the world but Spirits can Inspire the
living to be good members of the
community and work to build a better
tomorrow but I said previously tyrions
are free to believe what they want and
thanks to many species coming together
over the years sometimes have been known
to embrace the asari philosophy called
siarist or even human religions like
Confucianism and Buddhism the one area
area of expertise they lack though is
diplomacy the turian culture is based
around honor personal accountability and
setting aside personal desires for the
good of all they've had to rely on the
solarians for military intelligence and
the asari for diplomacy in order to keep
themselves in check speaking of those
two they had the other two Council races
the asari were the first to discover the
Citadel with the solarians following
shortly after these two races came
together to form the council in order to
maintain peace throughout the Galaxy the
asari are a monogendered race according
to Liara one of our future companions
she says that male and female genders
don't exist within the asari they don't
have any concept of gender in their
society like other races do however
Liara uses words like she and her which
would be feminine pronouns except those
shouldn't exist if there's no concept of
gender I think this detail is a small
glimpse into how the species of the
world have influenced one another to us
as humans the asari look feminine but to
them they're just asari they don't know
what male and female are but in order to
make it less confusing for the other
races they use the words she and her
since two and other species they would
be seen as an all-female Society despite
looking quite young they're actually
pretty old when compared to normal human
lifespans asari can live for over 1 000
years meaning that people like Liara who
are only around 106 are still pretty
young they go through various stages
during their lifetime the final one
being The Matriarch stage where they
take up roles as leaders and counselors
they also have a very unique form of
sexual intercourse as asari don't mate
in the traditional way but instead
reproduce through a form of
partheniogenesis they can attune their
mind to match their partners and
basically copy their genes this copied
selection of genes is altered in a
process called melding this connects the
two minds together allowing them to
share memories thoughts and feelings how
this creates a child is unclear and it's
also unclear how the process really
works because Shepard has this happen to
him three times throughout the game and
there is no mention of a kid resulting
from this so my hypothesis is that the
asari involved has to actually have
feelings centered around mating for it
to occur since in this case it was more
about giving Shepard more visions of
what what we saw earlier so Liara wasn't
doing the melding with the intention of
reproduction thus a child isn't made due
to this unique form of reproduction they
could bait with any species in the
Galaxy since no physical contact is
required but The Offspring is always
going to be an asari no matter the
father to asari of course can also
reproduce as well so the role of the
father is given to the one not giving
birth to the child the result of tuasari
mating is still another asari but
they're considered pure Bloods as their
genes come from tuasari rather than just
another species this is frowned upon by
many within their culture as when an
asari mates with another species they
can gain the memories of that person
which not only grows their own
individual understanding of their
partner but their history as well
allowing the asari race as a whole to
understand the races of the Galaxy
better so when to asari mate there are
no memories or traits being passed on so
it's sort of seen as a waste of time
pure bullets also have another stigma
attached to them which is that they can
possibly be Arda yakshi this is a
genetic mutation that is assumed to only
be in pure blood asari however this
isn't mentioned in Mass Effect 1 so
we'll talk about this more in the sequel
where it is mentioned as for things
other than intercourse we know from the
previous race that asari are excellent
at diplomacy but they're also very
tactical in their decisions waiting and
studying rather than immediate action is
how they've managed to become one of the
most powerful races in the Galaxy this
is also helped by their military
strength as well not as large or as
powerful as some of the species asari
are trained in biotics and are almost
impossible to beat when faced one-on-one
against the group though they're not too
powerful and this goes for any group
encounter since they usually have
smaller numbered units and only use
small support weapons as a backup making
War not exactly ideal for the asari
which is why they prefer to fight
diplomatically the asari aren't the only
race with small and Nimble Fighters
though but while they may still be
considered small fish in a big pond the
solarians are anything but weak
solarians are known for their
intelligence both on and off the
battlefield solarians are always seen
striking first even when on the
defensive they see the human concept of
do not fire until fired upon as
incredibly naive off the battlefield
you'll see many solarians in political
or leadership positions like the head
doctor of a medical clinic or the CEO of
a big company the reason for their
success in achieving these positions is
because of their hyperactive metabolism
they think walk and talk extremely fast
this allows them to do multiple tasks at
once and couple with their innate desire
to always innovate it's no wonder why
the species is so successful the
downside of this metabolism though is
that their bodies are also speeding up
which leads to a relatively short
lifespan a solarion over 40 is
considered a rarity this is a general
idea of the races that make up the
council and while we still have more to
go through these details are already
showing us how different each race is
from one another and even how these
races can coexist and change some of
their Customs to benefit others the
taurians asari and solarians make up the
council's races also known as the three
most politically important races in the
Galaxy but that doesn't mean the other
races aren't as important within Mass
Effect 1 5 races have the most detailed
backstories three of them we've already
discussed but the other two are the
Krogan and the quarians the Krogan are a
very primitive species they even cause
their their own nuclear winter at one
point solarians had made contact with
them very early on and culturally
uplifted them by teaching the Krogan how
to use and build modern technology the
reason the solarians did this though was
not because of some altruistic mindset
but because they wanted the Krogan to
help defeat the rakdai Iraq and I were a
species of sentient insects that were
growing too fast and were dead set on
conquering other worlds so the council
waged war on them and the solarians use
the Krogan as fodder due to their tough
shells and naturally strong physique
they wrote to fight back against the
rachni and not only win but literally
erase them from existence the Krogan
were thanked for their recent genocide
and were able to thrive on their own but
this caused another issue similar to the
rachnine now that the Krogan weren't
stuck on their dying Planet they were
able to colonize other planets and
reproduce at a staggering rate this led
to a rebellion from the Krogan which
lasted an entire Century until the
tyrions with the help of the solarians
created a bio weapon called the
genophage the genophage is key to
understanding Krogan culture because it
had completely shaped their entire
species 99 of the Krogan in the Galaxy
were infected by this bio weapon and the
effect of this chemical was the
prevention of pregnancy even having a
sign of life in the womb is now
considered a miracle one in one thousand
pregnancies actually succeed making the
Krogan a Dying Breed Women Within the
species especially ones that are still
fertile are seen as prized possessions
that the men fight and kill over but
while this may seem dangerous to the
women no harm actually comes to them as
hurting or killing a female Krogan is
punishable by death due to the genophage
though many Krogan have lost hope in
their race you'll see many of them like
Rex just take up mercenary work due to
their natural strength and love for
violence as killing for credits is a lot
simpler than trying to save your entire
race as for the quarians they don't
actually make an appearance in this game
with the exception of Tali I wanted to
include them anyway since tally is a
companion but the reason they aren't
seen in this game actually ties into
their backstory the quarians are fairly
Advanced when it comes to technology as
they are the creators of the death yes
the same group that is under sarin's
control was created by the quarians
they'd originally intended to just
create Advanced machines and use them as
workers and laborers the council though
has very strict laws when it come comes
to artificial intelligence because of
something like this according to Tali
what they did wasn't illegal but they
were definitely straddling that line
constantly to make the Geth more
efficient they slowly introduce more
complex tasks which ended up creating a
more sophisticated neural network Tali
says that the gats sort of feed off each
other and in layman's terms the more
Geth there are together the smarter they
are the problem though is that because
each Geth was slowly becoming smarter
from these new complex tasks they were
introduced to it caused the Geth hive
mind for a lack of a better word to grow
as well eventually causing them to
become sentient this was all discovered
when one of the Geth came in for testing
and asked what it means to live and what
its true purpose was the corians were
rightfully shocked by this discovery and
had ordered all Geth to be scrapped but
since they were sentient they had
developed feelings so instead of just
letting it happen they were scared of
thought of being killed so they fought
back the Geth managed to win and drive
out the entire Korean species from their
own planet and now all of them live
together on a cluster of ships they call
the migrant Fleet but living on the ship
isn't great there are about 17 million
corians living together in one place
which can make things cramped
furthermore there is a reason tally
wears a mask at all times since the ship
is a sterile environment and never
changes it's caused their immune systems
to weaken so much so that they risk
death even if they take it off for a few
seconds to make matters worse once they
reach a certain age Corian are forced to
leave the ship and cannot come back
until they return with something of
value usually this is in the form of
Geth data or something that could help
the fleet this is what they call the
quarian pilgrimage and is actually why
Tali is here in the first place these
are the five main species of Mass Effect
there are three others that we can meet
in the game though but since they aren't
as important and aren't given much
screen time the knowledge of their
history is quite limited the Volus are a
group of short and round people who can
be spotted buying and selling at the
markets and can also be seen holding
jobs related to trade and commerce in
fact many Volus watch over the citadel's
funds similar to the Koreans they have
to wear pressure suits and rebreathers
to be able to survive outside their own
Planet they also have an interesting
dialect and that they say things like
Earth Clan instead of human and
sometimes sound like they have trouble
breathing
lying
why would I lie to you the El core are
massive creatures and due to their size
and their home world's gravity they've
learned to speak and move slower than
most the most unique part of their
species is also their dialect since
their speech is very ponderous and
monotone they often start a sentence
with the emotion they are feeling
startled realization
I must speak with the consort
she will be most displeased with my
anxious request
please human if you will excuse me I
must go now the final race is the hanar
and they are some of the most polite
people in the Galaxy they find improper
language to be rude and hurtful which is
why they don't use such words but they
do recognize that not everyone thinks as
they do so they try their best to
unlearn these Tendencies and accept that
some people may just prefer to use
improper language if necessary the hanar
also like to use words like this one or
it when referring to themselves because
they find it egotistical to say their
actual names in conversation unless it's
among close friends the other detail
that makes them stand out to Saturn
their design is their desire to worship
and preach about their gods who they
call the inkindlers the inkindlers are
actually what they call the protheans
those beings that were wiped out
mysteriously over 50 000 years ago their
Homeworld has quite a few prothean ruins
on it so once they were discovered many
of them started worshiping them as Gods
this is currently all the races within
Mass Effect I think the length of this
section alone reinforces my earlier
statement that each of the races within
the game are so diverse from their
design to their backstories but honestly
we've only been really touched upon a
small section of this massive world not
only are there tons of details on the
current races I left out for the sake of
Simplicity but there are a few races we
haven't even talked about yet by far the
best part about all of this though is
that this can all be found within the
game itself you gain all this
information not only by talking with
various species but also by looking at
the game's codex which provides tons of
detailed information you wouldn't find
anywhere else I understand though not
everyone is Keen on reading dozens of
pages just to find out information but
the point is that BioWare did an
incredible job when it comes to this
game's aliens each one is so distinct in
its designed that it's almost impossible
to mistake them and their backstories
make them stand out from everyone else
in the Galaxy whether that be their
gender culture history or physique each
one was delicately handcrafted to create
a fleshed out and expansive world and it
is without a doubt the strongest part of
mass effect's writing now I know that
section was quite long but I wanted to
mention these details that you can keep
these in your mind not just throughout
this video but in the future episodes as
a lot of the interactions in this game
make sense when you take into account
their backstories like how the leader of
the executive board on noveria is a
solarian and how some tyrions have a
strong dislike towards humans since they
fought them in the contact Wars
furthermore many actions and
consequences that will be made
throughout the series were because of
their history and their culture in fact
we can even see some of these now
reflecting in our companions but at the
moment we're still missing one so let's
go find her to refresh her memory
Shepard just came back from Eden Prime
and was denied by the council when he
came forth with accusations against
saren to prove his statement he seeks
out Garrus AC Tech investigator who is
working on the investigation against
saren he however was forbidden from
looking further into the case later the
group will then be direct say gun for
hire who used to work for sarin on a
prior Mission then Talia a Korean woman
who claims to have evidence against
saren see Tali was looking for a place
to hide so she contacted a man named
fist fist works for the shadow broker an
enigmatic person who runs a large
Enterprise that trades money for
information chances are if you've done
something Shady or even have some
relevance in Galactic space the shadow
broker knows he were tally wanted to
trade the information she had regarding
sarin going rogue so that she could get
off the hook and wouldn't be hunted down
tally also explains how she came across
this information which is that she was
able to salvage a Geth memory core and
keep its data this goes back to what I
said earlier about specific actions
making more sense when the history is
explained no one would willingly try to
salvage gas Tech unless they were
Aquarian furthermore it's known that
there is a defense mechanism in the Geth
to stop this from happening but who
other than Aquarian would know how to
bypass it it's just genius writing
getting back to fist though the guy is
not too smart he attempted to play The
Shadow broker by taking the deal to
sarin instead of him the shadow broker
doesn't take this kind of thing lying
down so he hired Rex to take fist out
for betraying him Shepard then works
with Rex to hunt fist down and then
saves Tally from a potential
assassination as thanks for saving her
Tali then presents the evidence to udina
and Anderson
Eden Prime was a major victory
plus one step closer to finding the
conduit
and one step closer to the return of the
Reapers
that's some pretty damaging evidence and
will not make saren look good the other
voice on the audio tape was Matrix
benezia who we briefly mentioned earlier
Matrix are very old members of the asari
race and are likely anywhere between 750
and a thousand years old given her
status and the knowledge he gained from
being this old she is clearly a
formidable foe but the question of why
she joined saren has yet to be answered
the reason I brought her up was because
of what she said regarding the return of
the Reapers the reapers are the reason
the protheans were wiped out fifty
thousand years ago we still don't know
why or how that was possible but at
least we know the cause of the protein
Extinction this has now turned things
from bad to worse if saren is trying to
recruit or resurrect a group of beings
that wiped out an entire race then the
whole galaxy is in danger the council
hears this information but refuses to
arrest or even kill him for his actions
the council is worried that this could
trigger a war with the Terminus systems
it's probably a good time to mention
this but Mass Effect takes place in the
Milky Way galaxy the lower parts of the
Galaxy are the council and Alliance
controlled spaces with the upper Parts
being the turn Terminus systems the
council refuses to budge on this
decision but Shepard asks if he can go
alone the council agrees but because
this mission is also a galactic problem
the great Shepard the title of Specter
making him the first two minutes Vector
in the Galaxy honestly no matter how
many times I play this game I can never
really get over this induction ceremony
the council then forwards us the
relevant files which points us towards
three locations there have been
sightings of Geth on the planet's Pharos
and noveria and the other lead is on
matrak benezia's daughter named Liara to
Sony who was last seen at an
archaeological digsite near the Artemis
Tau cluster it's important that we find
her as she may have answers as to why
matriarch Venezia has joined sarin and
what's Aaron plans to do with the
conduit and the death from here you're
pretty much allowed to go wherever you
want but I usually go with pharaohs
first so we'll start there one reason
Pharaoh stands out is because of its
plot twist it's nothing revolutionary
but pharaohs had originally been set up
as a routine death attack but the
thought of why they were here is still
in your mind now if you play this
immediately then pharaohs will serve its
purpose but I've always felt it loses
its appeal if you do the side content
before going here I'll elaborate more on
this later but when visiting a lot of
the planets in the game nine times out
of 10 the guest will attempt to stop you
it starts to lose its value after a
while because you just expect the Geth
to show up everywhere for no real
purpose which is what many may assume
Pharos is just a colony being attacked
by Geth that's why I've always felt that
you should do pharaohs as soon as
possible as the sense of mystery is
still present the only other time we've
seen Geth up until this point is to eat
in Prime and there was a reason for
their presence so the same can be
assumed for Pharaohs after helping some
of the colonists we can continue to
explore the settlements and may come
across Ian he's a little strange but his
placement here is a nice foreshadowing
of what's to come eventually it will
come across Juliana and Ethan Ethan is
very reluctant to explain what's going
on and it's clear he is hiding something
both of them work for a company called
exogeny this company specializes in
Planetary Exploration and colonization
in the case of pharaohs they sent a few
people down here to see if any profit
could be made off the planet sadly not
much was found here and many considered
it a dead Planet until they found the
thorian we learn a little bit about this
creature from Juliana's daughter and
even one of the VI's later at the
exogeny building but the thorogan seems
to be a sort of sentient plant that's
been around for a long time and has the
ability to send out spores into the air
which when inhaled by something can give
the thorian control over them Ethan from
earlier was a victim of this although he
was in the early stages of it where the
thorian controls these people it can sap
its memories from them which is why it's
become so intelligent the reason we know
that it has existed for a long time is
that it claims to have absorbed
Knowledge from the protheans it had
apparently gained so much knowledge from
them that it created what our characters
have called decipher the way we obtained
the cipher is from shigala who is
imprisoned in the thorogen by sarin she
worked alongside matriarch benezia but
was betrayed and forced to be part of
the thorian according to shiala Venezia
wanted to join sarin and guide him down
a gentler path but she ended up becoming
indoctrinated indoctrination is actually
defined as teaching something but the
reason it has a more negative
connotation is that it usually involves
hiding facts and disregarding other
outside opinions that don't fit the
narrative now CERN isn't really teaching
people any anything he's more just
brainwashing them to agree with his
opinion xiala and Venezia were
brainwashed into believing what saren
believes is the way saren is able to do
this because of his ship called
Sovereign Sovereign apparently has mind
control and brainwash capability similar
to the thorian whereas the thorian could
do this with spores that it released
from its body Sovereign seems to be able
to do it with an energy field that
surrounds it Sarah needed the thorium
because it had the cipher if we recall
our earlier encounter with the beacon on
Eden Prime all we saw were images and
Visions the reason it was unclear to us
was that these were made for a prothean
mind to understand it's the same way
that another language like Japanese
would not make any sense to someone
unless they understood that language the
cipher is what allows us to gain an
understanding of these Visions to
understand what they mean we need to
think like a prothean we need to
understand their culture their history
and their existence I want to clarify
that the cipher isn't some physical
object or anything of the sort basically
without it it's like trying to explain
color to someone without eyes it's hard
to explain what the color red is like to
someone who doesn't even know what color
is science fiction action is known to
have complex and intricate Concepts like
this and I love how detailed this one
piece of story was and it also continues
to add to the mystery of who these
prothians really were Shepard with the
help of shiala gains access to the
cipher and the scene always gives me the
chills
foreign
so with the cipher Shepard should be
able to understand what these Visions
mean well not quite think of these
Visions as a puzzle without the cipher
they're just a blank puzzle made of just
white pieces with the cipher we can
actually see the puzzle but we still
have only completed part of it we could
see that something is there but we can't
get the full picture until we put all
the pieces together thankfully we still
have a few more places to go so
hopefully we can get more information
from them our next location is noveria
and it's here where I actually want to
highlight a couple things more often
than not massive active will reward you
for thinking outside the box naveria is
where matriarch benezia is located and
we know that she's an asari we also know
that Liara is an asari and will
eventually become a companion so instead
if we do liara's Mission first and then
bring her to noveria and find benezia we
can actually get some unique dialogue
with her this has always been my
favorite part about the series as you
would expect Liara of all people to have
thoughts on this considering not only is
she an asari but she's also her daughter
which is something we learn if we rescue
her these small interactions are
incredible and I always try to find ways
to get this dialogue to happen like
bringing tally to places with Geth since
those beings drove out her people it
doesn't happen all the time but it feels
great to guess right and see some
dialogue you may not have heard
otherwise the other interactions I like
are usually in the elevators when at the
Citadel news anchors may come on and
talk about things we did in side
missions sometimes though banter can
just occur between the group after years
of poor economic performance exogeny has
announced that its research Colony on
Pharos is finally returning a profit
new discoveries and a dedicated
colonization effort have finally paid
off for exogeny exogeny stock Rose
sharply with the announcement with
investors pleased at this surprising
news
never regret leaving Citadel security to
pursue serengetas
fighting a rogue Specter with countless
lives at stake and no regulations to get
in the way I'd say that beats
I'm pleased that the imminent
destruction of all organic life has
improved your career opportunities
it's the little things that stand out
most in games like this and these
interactions make things feel alive in
the world of Mass Effect our actions
have direct consequences on the world
around us even if we never see these
outcomes in the game and companions can
either throw out a joke or two or even
give us information we didn't know about
this is one of the main reasons I find
myself coming back to these games all
the time is not only does talking with
different companions reward us with
different dialogue but if we manage to
bring a specific pair we can hear even
more getting back to noveria we
discovered that Venezia was here and is
at the peak 15 research facility it's a
pain to get there but after some time we
arrive and find Geth at the facility but
not only are there Geth here the rachni
are here as well we briefly mentioned
them when we talked about the Krogan but
I said that the Krogan killed off all
the ragnae that wasn't false information
they are supposed to be extinct which
makes this discovery even more confusing
apparently a group of researchers found
a derelict ship in space and found a
brachni egg but it wasn't just any egg
it was the Egg of arachni Queen this was
a huge Discovery so the group
immediately got to work on research the
group of research Chargers work for a
company called binary Helix they focus
on biotechnology and genetic engineering
but just like exogeny they're a bit
corrupt in their methods they wanted to
create an army of arachni using the
queen however they also wanted to make a
bioweapon to kill off the arachni in
case things went wrong but creating a
weapon just for the Rock and I wouldn't
provide much value to the company
especially considering no one even knows
the Rock and I were alive to begin with
so they attempted to make it affect
other species as well to make matters
worse apparently sarin and Venezia were
key investors of binary Helix so they
had some control over their projects
sarin wanted the ragnites who serve as a
part of his army but something went
wrong and the rack and I escape
containment upon reaching the core of
the facility we will eventually find
matriaric benezia
confrontation we are is here because
she's a member of my crew
should I explain how to kill you what
could I say
like I said I love these small
interactions that can come if you bring
a certain crew member along but as he
had despite being a matriarch arguably
one of the most powerful beings in the
galaxy is actually quite easy to defeat
now this is down to numerous factors I
did this mission after about four hours
of side content so I was pretty over
Geared for the encounter and Mass Effect
isn't exactly a hard game in general
also according to my research the
legendary edition also changed this
fight quite a bit the fight is three
waves of asari and Geth before fighting
benezia at the end the verse 3 waves
have less Geth and less asari than
before and Venezia fights alone this
time as opposed to having another
Commando with her like in the original
they also removed her ability to attack
the player with biotics during these
waves according to an interview with one
of the directors of BioWare they also
made the pathways bigger and added more
cover since a lot of the room was either
no cover or just movable boxes I
remember that being a huge pain in the
ass back then so I'm glad this was
changed but I always thought that was
the main reason it was so difficult not
the enemies themselves it's been a long
time since I've played the original so I
could be misremembering a lot of details
but I do remember this fight being a lot
harder when there were more Commandos
but not so much harder that it was
impossible asari Commandos are supposed
to be tough so I figured their
difficulty was perfectly acceptable
after the boss fight we can speak with
benezia and discover that she was also
indoctrinated by saren CERN wanted her
to find something called the MU relay
but she was unsuccessful the reason she
came here was that The Rock and I used
to live near that region of the Galaxy
and also discovered the relay themselves
the rec and I share memories across
generations and a queen can pass on this
info to their daughters but Asia
realizing the error of her ways made a
backup of the data from the rachni and
gives it to us on an OSD Venezia fights
us because of her indoctrination but
once defeated again she will succumbed
to her wounds afterward though is where
we are given a choice the rachni queen
is alive and we are tasked with sparing
her or we can kill her effectively
making the rack not extinct again one
thing I really like is that our
companions have actual opinions on the
subject although ultimately the decision
does come down to us given what we know
of the rock night it would seem like
killing them would be the better outcome
but do we have the right to make a
decision like this who would have the
right to make a decision like this it's
honestly a question I still think about
because the world has been fine without
them for two thousand years so it's not
like their Extinction ruined the
ecosystem it's like bees and spiders I
hate both of these insects but without
them our ecosystem could become worse
Iraq and I didn't seem to have that
effect as far as we can tell but we also
have to consider that the Ragtime aren't
just insects despite their appearance
they're a sentient race of people just
like all the other races we've met so
far I think if I had to make the choice
I would probably choose to spare them I
wouldn't feel too confident in my
decision but I would hope that Liara is
right and that they can atone for what
they did it's honestly a pretty tough
choice and I would love to hear your
decision as to why after this decision
though we complete the mission and we
can now report back to the console the
one thing I hate about this meeting is
that the turian council member scolds us
regardless of our decision he hates that
we saved the queen but also berates us
if we kill her what they could have done
was just make the solarion have the
opposite Viewpoint or even the asari
council member chime in but by having
the Tyrion be the opposing Force each
time it proves that this was just added
to make the player feel indifferent
about their decision and not because the
council member actually had a problem
with the choice our final mission now is
to find Liara to Sony I added this one
at the end because there's honestly not
that much that is too important layara
does have some comedic dialogue if this
is done last though as if we rescue her
first then everything is fine what if we
do the mission last then she will
believe that she's hallucinating and
that her mind is conjured up someone who
will save her Liara doesn't really help
us though she just transfers some of her
knowledge to us but it's just stuff we
already know one thing we do learn from
her though is that the prothean's dying
was a part of a cycle they are also says
that the mass relays and the citadels
were not created by the protheans they
were technology created by a previous
Civilization now things are starting to
make less sense the protheans didn't
make these devices and weren't the first
species to be wiped out from Extinction
we still don't understand why though we
know the Reapers wipe them out but can
we be certain that the reapers are
behind all the killings or if they're
just responsible for the protein
Extinction it also doesn't make sense as
to why there are rarely any traces of
Reapers at all despite wiping out the
Galaxy but with this though we're stuck
and have no leads that is until the
council comes back and says that one of
the infiltration units on a planet
called vermeier might have some
information on sarin they sent a message
to the council but it was static however
it was received from their specific
channel that is only for Mission
critical communication so it had to be
important this however is a big mission
and if saren is going to be there we're
going to need to be ready for anything
so before we go to vermeier let's talk
about our Companions and some of the
game's side content
[Music]
Mass Effect is all about exploration
it's the reason why the story even
exists as sentient creatures we have
this innate desire to explore we've done
this with our own Planet but now that we
have a galaxy of planets at our
fingertips we're free to go where we
want there's so much mystery Behind
These planets and so many questions come
from these Mysteries like what is on
this planet is it dangerous can it be
colonized or are we the first people to
set foot on this land the sense of
mystery is present in all these planets
but by the time you actually arrive most
of the enjoyment is gone any place that
isn't a part of the main quest gets
little to no attention from both the
players and designers places like the
Citadel are the opposite as they are
beautifully crafted and provide players
with tons of content to do which is why
so many quests end up appearing here but
many of the missions on the Citadel are
just fluff that's not really a bad thing
though a lot of the questions revolve
around small issue that some people are
having like this is sorry who wants us
to stop someone from spreading rumors
about her or this guy who's trying to
get some meds because he's addicted to
them they're not bad quests but since
many of them don't have much story to
them there isn't much reason to talk
about them in this video but the Citadel
isn't the only place you can find side
quests you can also explore the Galaxy
although I use the word explore pretty
Loosely there are a lot of clusters and
systems in the Milky Way and within all
of them are lots of different planets
ninety percent of the planets though
cannot be entered most of the time
you'll be able to read a quick
description of the planets but how long
that description is will depend on which
one you're looking at sometimes though
you can survey planets and they'll
provide you with some asari writings dog
tags medallions or some minerals all of
a doe is pretty much useless and I'm
pretty sure the Collectibles don't even
reward you with anything minus a small
bit of XP in credits I guess it could
have been created to encourage
exploration but if they wanted to do
that then they should have made the
exploration actually fun on the small
chance you can actually land on a planet
you're allowed to drive around in the
Mako and explore its world this mostly
means going to the three markers on your
map and doing whatever they want you to
do then leave sometimes other markers
will appear but only when you drive near
them but it's not even really worth it
after going through all the planets for
around 4 hours I gave up going to any of
these other locations about halfway
through and just went to any markers
labeled Geth Outpost and research lab
the terrain is also just Barren and
empty I understand that not every planet
will be colonized so sometimes there
just isn't things to look at but just
about every planet is empty except those
markers all the assets are also reused
constantly and it starts to become more
and more irritating when every single
Building looks the same and all the
Interiors are the exact same layout the
missions on these planets aren't really
that great either many of the missions
revolve around the player finding out
what happened to some of the colonists
on these planets and it almost always
boils down to the Geth which is another
thing I'm confused about why are there
death here I feel like there is no
strategical advantage to constructing an
outpost in the middle of nowhere some of
these places barely even have anybody
living on them so I have to ask why
there are bases here not all the
missions revolve around the the Geth
though some involve Shepard getting
trapped in a room by some random Tyrion
who locks Us in with a literal nuclear
bomb that Shepard can just disarm with
no problem or even Force the crew to
find a module within a pack of monkeys
I'm pretty sure I audibly sighed when I
got that Quest it's not all bad though
sometimes we are allowed to visit space
stations and while they also boil down
to the same thing as the planets this
one in particular had an interesting
story apparently this girl's lover was
going to be put down because his brain
was deprived of oxygen for too long and
it doesn't look like he'll make a
recovery they wanted him to die with
dignity but Julia didn't want him to she
went into a severe depression because of
this but despite being given meds for
her condition she refused to take them
and ended up killing the whole crew once
we find out what happened to her lover
Julia will attempt to Ambush us but she
gets killed right away one thing I
really enjoyed about this questline was
that I had to sort of show don't tell
style of writing I wasn't forced to open
these terminals I wasn't even really
forced to come here so all this was
discovered on my own which would be the
point of Planet exploration the main
reason you're doing this is to uncover
its Mysteries sadly this is rare as in
most cases it'll just be something like
what you see on screen a pop-up will
appear detailing something that didn't
even happen you don't hear music in this
room and this video of Aquarion never
actually appears this isn't D and D
where I need descriptive details so I
can imagine the world around me I'm
literally playing the game play the
video clip and just let me interpret
what I saw it just makes all these
encounters a waste of time because all
I'm doing is shooting stuff then reading
text on my screen rather than just
actually seeing it for myself overall
though the space station mission was a
pretty nice Quest it's short but sweet
and that's the issue if this was on the
low end of quest then that's fine it's a
small Quest maybe not too memorable but
it was there to tell a different story
but because this Quest had a story it
automatically shoots up to the Top If
this Quest is the ceiling for Quality we
are doomed thankfully that's not all the
galaxy has to offer as we can travel to
the Moon and come across a distressed
Beacon but when we complete the quest we
get a bunch of numbers on our screen and
when the binary code is translated it
reads the word help according to the
mission assignment it seemed like a VI
had gained sentience at one point this
was a great discovery as it also
connects to a lot of the game's core
themes which is about synthetic versus
organic life since that is becoming
sentient like the Geth could be a
problem so hearing that a random VI also
gained this is a bit nerve-wracking but
not as nerve-wracking as discovering
Cerberus through our exploration we can
find some details about a pro-human
organization called Cerberus and after
some time we'll find their other bases
throughout the Galaxy inside these bases
we can see that they're experimenting
with different creatures and even humans
it's not incredibly interesting at the
moment but Cerberus does become a pretty
big deal later in the sequels which is
why I've always appreciated this Quest
the final one I do want to talk about
though is this mission on an asteroid
apparently this small asteroid is
heading towards a planet and if it's not
stopped it will kill millions of people
upon arriving we're tasked with shutting
these Fusion torches down so we can
alter its course preventing us from
doing so though is a new race of beings
called batarians they aren't seen much
in Mass Effect 1 because they usually
reside in the Terminus systems the
batarians were welcome to the galactic
Community about a few hundred years ago
but they cause a lot of hostility they
raided many colonies that belong to all
types of races until the console had to
step in and put a stop to them around
the time humans gained the ability to
colonize other planets they asked the
council to intervene as they claimed
that the humans were colonizing batarian
land the council refused and in response
the battarians removed themselves from
The Citadel and the council space the
group on this asteroid are a bunch of
batarian extremists who claim that the
people on this asteroid need to be
punished because they're colonizing a
world that could have been theirs and
taking resources that also could have
been theirs their leader balik blames
the humans for why they're in this
current position I don't think I need to
explain how insane that thinking is but
you are forced to let him go if you want
to save the colonists as he has
explosives rigged to explode if we
retaliate this was probably the best
quest in the game but that's because
it's DLC because of course it is this
Quest had a cut scene with it of course
it was DLC it's pretty clear that in the
base game of Mass Effect a lot of the
exploration is pretty poor the side
quests aren't that interesting and a lot
of the worlds are Barren but the one
redeeming quality to them is only
achieved by looking up
these planets have some of the most
gorgeous Sky boxes I have ever seen it's
also the main reason I miss this kind of
content as Mass Effect 2 changed the
exploration system and while it does
have its perks nothing is as fun as
landing on a planet and looking at the
sky the Galaxy can get lonely especially
when you stare at the planets nearby and
realize how small you truly are but it
doesn't have to be done alone your
companions are more than happy to join
you on your planetary excursions and
even help you take down sarin the first
question we have to ask though is
whether their reasons make sense
oftentimes a game will force characters
onto the player so that they can use
them in their team without considering
if they would actually have joined them
in the first place and after some
careful consideration all the reasons
are pretty much genuine Kaden was with
us from the very beginning so he gets a
pass Ashley who we meet on Eden Prime
very early in the game also stays with
us because her Squad was killed and
seeing as she already worked for the
alliance Anderson likely just moved her
to our team Garris who originally worked
for c-sec left to join Shepard because
he still wanted to enact justice but
without all the red tape and politics
that comes at being an officer Rex at
his core is still a Merc plus he's a
Krogan and they love to fight he luckily
saw how Shepard was able to handle
himself in a fight and figure joining up
would mean they get into some pretty
good fire fights tally joins up because
she wants to complete her pilgrimage and
Liara is fond of Shepard because she
likes prothean technology and
considering Shepard has been seeing
visions of the protheans this is more
than enough to convince her to stay so
all in all all the motivations are there
some could be a stretch and possibly
debated but I think it works for the
most part and I'm glad BioWare took the
time to consider why they would joined
Shepherd in the first place besides that
though we can also learn more about
their backstories but most of them
connect to why they joined Shepard in
the first place as stated before Liara
likes prothean Tech Tali needs to
complete her pilgrimage and we can give
her guest data at one point for her to
take back to her people and Garris has a
sense of justice which is why he left
csec to join Shepard and we can help him
by capturing a killer he wasn't able to
bring to Justice while under seasek this
is not bad by any means though I really
like how their reasons for joining
Shepard or their backstories I'll link
back to their racist history another
great example of this though would be
Rex and Ashley Rex was actually against
the Krogan Rebellion at least when the
genophage came because he knew they
didn't have the numbers to win this
caused some chaos amongst the Krogan
Clans as the species couldn't agree on a
specific Viewpoint so to settle things
out he met with the opposing viewpoints
leader who was his father Gerard the two
talked but when it became clear that Rex
wasn't budging his father launched a
surprise attack that killed all of Rex's
men Rex luckily somehow survived the
encounter but only because he had to
kill his father to do so that day ended
up changing Rex as he has since lost
open his people and now just takes up
mercenary work since killing crew
credits ends up simplifying things
Ashley has a sort of pessimistic
Viewpoint of the world and even outright
says that she doesn't trust the other
alien crew members this stems from the
fact that her family had served in the
military for Generation so they've
always put Humanity's needs first plus
her thinking that the other races would
likely care about their own race rather
than helping others if the going gets
tough is a plausible Theory most people
would protect their own family before
others so it makes sense that other
races would think the same way plus
Humanity didn't exactly get the greatest
greeting when meeting a other species
for the first time this has caused her
to be resentful of the new crew as she
deems them all to be untrustworthy the
only outlier in this situation is Kaden
but his story is still pretty
interesting Kaden was accidentally
exposed to a substance called element
zero in the womb this gave him biotic
abilities which is a lucky break as most
kids that got exposed to it just got
brain cancer he was then sent to a place
the kids called brain camp where they
were encouraged to commit to an
evaluation of their ability so that they
could have a better understanding of how
their biotics worked the company behind
this Camp though got greedy and wanted
to speed up the process so they hired an
ex-military turian Commander to help
train the children his training was
brutal and during one of his training
sessions Caden snapped when the turian
commander broke the arm of the girl he
liked at the facility Kaden then fought
the commander and killed him immediately
after the incident the facility was shot
down and the records are wiped that's a
pretty rough story and also gives us a
look at to what was going on years ago
when biotics were first being introduced
the humans at the time biotic Powers
were relatively new so testing and
research were required but the company
when he got greedy and paid the price
for it all of Mass Effect 1's characters
are extremely interesting and I like how
not all of them were made to be these
perfect beings with zero flaws some of
these characters can not only disagree
with the player but also clash with
other companions these characters also
don't share the same reasons for joining
Liara is a great example as while she
likely does want to take down saren
she's definitely more focused on
learning about the protheans which is
why she's even with Shepard to begin
with this is in stark contrast to
someone like Garris whose main goal is
to enact Justice and take down saren
creating a cast of characters that all
join for different reasons and have the
possibility to have contrasting
viewpoints to the player and the team is
a great way to create a believable and
diverse cast the only problem I have is
that they don't really disapprove of
Shepard's actions a lot of our crew will
Express a specific viewpoint on the
rachni queen decision but no matter what
we choose they won't say anything about
it and will continue to work with us the
only character that doesn't do this is
Rex as we'll see later but this has
always stuck out to me as odd despite
disagreeing with us they still continue
to stay in the ship and help could you
say that it's because there are bigger
more important things at stake than
friendship absolutely but I think this
ends up plaguing the entire Trilogy this
is more prevalent in the sequel which
we'll discuss then but it's always been
odd how no matter what happens your crew
is willing to always stick by you even
if you go against what they believe in
Rex is the only character in this game
so far that makes any sort of personal
decision which is incredible and I wish
more of this actually happened to
explain what I mean though we should
probably get back to the story with all
that finished we can now return to where
we left off which is the planet vermeyer
the place where an infiltration team had
sent a message to the council regarding
sarin but it couldn't be heard as the
connection was too spotty we touched
down on vermeier and as expected we find
lots of gas after battling through
dozens of troops we meet with the
commander of the Squad Captain kirihi
explains that this area is saren's base
of operations and there is a research
facility ahead the research is
apparently a cure for the genophage as
he's trying to breed a army of Krogan
Rex is clearly interested in this
discovery but Captain kirihee says that
the Cure is too dangerous and thus needs
to be destroyed along with the facility
Rex does not take a liking to this and
immediately storms off here is where we
have to make arguably one of the biggest
decisions in the game Rex refuses to let
this place be destroyed and will
literally kill Shepard if he has to if
we don't say the correct answers we're
forced to put him down but because we
helped him find his family armor we can
tell him that we care about him and that
he needs to trust us one criticism
regarding this mission is how we can't
get the Cure and destroy the base at the
same time I think this problem was
caused by the solarian from earlier
because his idea is incredibly naive I
don't think a cure actually existed he
just assumes so since sarin wanted to
make the Krogan I'm convinced that saren
was just cloning them so that he could
make an army there was no actual cure
involved in this process even if there
was it's likely that them becoming Saran
slaves were a part of the Cure or at
least used as a bargaining chip Rex even
starts to talk about saren being the
good guy in this scenario because he's
curing his people so saren likely could
have been claiming that a cure was made
so that he would draw Krogan in and
indoctrinate them regardless it's clear
that destroying the facility would be
more beneficial to the Krogan then
letting the Cure survive after Talking
Rex down we'll work with Captain kirihi
to devise a plan we're then going to go
around the back to make certain believe
that these solarians are the real threat
we'll then slip in and plant the bomb
needed to blow up the facility and its
research but on the way we run into
something that changes this game's story
forever
what is that some kind of VI interface
rudimentary creatures of blood and flesh
drops my mind fumbling in
I don't think this is a VI there is a
realm of existence so far beyond your
own you cannot even imagine it I am
I am sovereign
isn't just some Reaper ship saren found
actual Reaper Shepard is correct
Sovereign was not just some Reaper ship
saren used but an actual Reaper our
discussion with Sovereign changes
everything we've known about this game
up until now the reapers are indeed the
reason the protheans were wiped out 50
000 years ago the reason Sovereign is
alive despite being 50 000 years old is
because he's synthetic organic life like
humans have lifespans but machines we
create in factories do not synthetic
life has no lifespan as they don't have
any working organs that shut down over
some time the reapers are synthetic so
they continue to exist even for
thousands or millions of years Sovereign
says that they are the Pinnacle of
existence and nothing is better than the
Reapers the reapers are also the cause
for all life being wiped out since their
existence every cycle a new civilization
is born then they advance in technology
and space travel but once they've gone
too far they're then killed off by the
Reapers this happened to the protheans
and now it's happening to us they use
the mass relays and the Citadel as tools
to make sure life in the Galaxy evolves
according to their plans it's because of
the mass relays that lie life in the
Galaxy was able to travel across space
and discover the Citadel the Reapers
made these devices on purpose so that
they could track how far life was
evolving once life in the Galaxy had
reached the Citadel and had started
using it the reefers would enact their
plan to wipe out all life in the Galaxy
why they do this though is unknown for
now but the idea that these beings are
so Advanced that we can't even grasp
their existence is not only chilling but
incredible in the context of the plot
sarin isn't the real threat here it is
and always has been the Reapers to make
the most sense of this discovery think
of the Reapers as the great filter kurz
gustad has an Incredible video on the
subject that I'll link down below if
you're confused but to Briefly summarize
many have hypothesized that there is a
reason we haven't seen life in the
Galaxy yet the reason is that the world
has a filter the question though is
where is it located there are nine steps
in the process of life we start with a
habitable planet then to reproductive
molecules to single cell life which then
goes to complex single cell life two
sexual reproduction multi-cell life tool
using animals with intelligence a civil
realization advancing towards a
potential colonization explosion and
then that explosion this basically in
simple terms is how life came to be on
earth the earth as a planet is safe
enough for people to live on it which is
step one then life gets created in the
form of a single cell organism which
then evolves into other organisms for
millions of years until it leads to us
step 7 is tool using animals with
intelligence humans pass this one we
became cavemen but it's also some other
animals as well monkeys have been known
to use rocks to break up on the shells
of animals so they've also reached step
seven step eight is a civilization
advancing towards the potential for a
colonization explosion we are the only
beings that have made it this far and
are stuck here because step nine is that
colonization explosion which basically
just means colonizing other planets in
our galaxy The Great filter is a barrier
that stops life from going past a
certain point that point is assumed to
be located on one of the nine steps I
just talked about if the filter is
behind us then that explains why we
don't find other life because we might
be the first life in the world to pass
the barrier if it's ahead of us then we
still have a ways to go but that would
mean we aren't Advanced enough to find
life yet however that also means the
filter has yet to hit us meaning we
haven't passed it and will likely be
killed off once we reach that point the
reapers are that filter if we're to look
at the chart again the Reapers would
appear around step 9 since humanity and
Mass Effect has already achieved this so
if there was a hypothetical step 10 then
the Reapers will attempt to stop us
before reaching that point which would
explain why every civilization in game
has been wiped out they were so close to
achieving that next step but the Reapers
stopped them we still however don't know
why the Reapers want to do this or what
the threshold even is the reapers are
clearly capable of wiping out a Galaxy
at any moment but they only do it once
life reaches a certain point however we
don't know what that point is just yet
this is why the reapers are so
fascinating the mystery behind them
makes this discovery in the context of
the plot create some of the best writing
I have ever seen in a game and as said
earlier this will change the entire
story going forward as now we know the
real threat we clearly have a lot of
questions but we're also in the middle
of a war so that needs to be dealt with
first and it's here where we get another
Choice Ashley and Caden are pinned down
at their positions and were only able to
save one now because I'm doing two
playthroughs I chose Ashley for the male
Shepard and Kaiden for the female
Shepherd because of the potential
romance options and any possible unique
dialogue that may come from those
relationships but if I was just doing
one playthrough and had to make a
genuine choice I would have probably
just picked Kaden I've always personally
enjoyed Kaden more than actually mostly
because I found him more interesting
which is why I usually go with him
shortly after this decision we will meet
sarin and this brings up a good point
the question Still Remains though what
does saren have to do with this well
he'll explain to us that once he
discovered Sovereign and what the
Reapers were capable of he essentially
gave up he knows that life as it is now
could not win so we figured surrendering
would be better he assumed that if the
prothians surrendered they would have
been spared so he wants Humanity to do
the same this is why he never brought
this up to the council because organic
life is driven by emotion rather than
logic so life in the Galaxy would still
fight the Reapers even if they know they
couldn't win CERN wants to save life in
the Galaxy by submitting to the Reapers
and hoping that they'll find us useful
enough to keep around yeah the Reapers
could still kill us if they deem life
useless but at least we tried fighting
to sarin is not trying because we're
doomed to fail anyway but by
surrendering we at least have a Fighting
Chance saren was aware that he could be
indoctrinated by now but he discovered
that the more you resist the worse it
gets so by sarin not resisting at all he
was able to still have some cognitive
function left in his brain where his
logic Falls flat though is that he
claims that Sovereign needs him to find
the conduit and that if he does he'll be
spared from Extinction which we know
just isn't going to happen I personally
believe that saren is not lying when he
says he's not indoctrinated yet but his
theory that he'll be spared if he
succeeds is false saren refuses to
listen to our pleas and reason so we're
forced to kill him but before we fight
he does tell us about the Geth and how
the gats see Sovereign as a God but it
is one-sided as Sovereign doesn't want
to be seen as a God and sees the Geth as
puppets and nothing more I really like
saren as an antagonist I do understand
where he is coming from to an extent if
a race of beings had wiped out all life
for millions of years what makes us
different fighting would be the
definition of insanity the protheans
fought back and failed and all the other
civilizations fought back and failed so
what makes us different a great
Counterpoint to this ideology is also
one of my favorite analogies and that's
a dig site if archaeologists spend 10
years digging a giant hole and find
nothing then they failed but the next
team that comes by the hole now has 10
years worth of work they don't need to
do and can pick up where the last group
left off and this could keep going and
going until someone finds what they were
originally looking for but here is where
the Reapers differ they erased all life
from the Galaxy and most of the species
Tech we barely find anything belonging
to the protheans plus they also have all
life on Earth using their technology
like the mass relays and the Citadel if
we go back to the dig site example the
reapers are not only covering up the dig
site every time the cycle starts but
also purposely picking a spot in the
Earth where the treasure they're seeking
is not going to be found there is no
group effort here we aren't using what
the proteins use to slowly but really
destroy them we're getting reset to zero
every single time
or
are we saren ends up escaping our fights
and we blow up the facility Lira
connects our minds again and she will
discover that there is a distressed call
coming from a planet called ilos we are
realizes this is why siren wanted to
find the MU really as it's the only way
to get into ilos we take this
information to the council and as you
would expect they don't believe us this
Trope is definitely starting to get old
really fast I wouldn't mind this
situation if only one of the council
members was adamant that were wrong but
it's the entire board Shepard has a
pretty good line here in which you can
tell them that at some point they're
going to have to take something he says
on faith I do understand where the
council is coming from though they not
only govern the lives of the Citadel but
the entire Council Galaxy trillions of
people will be affected by their
decisions which is exactly why they
created the specters people that can do
what they want when they want without
the need of the council making Galactic
decisions which is why it is so ironic
that they end up forcing Shepard to stay
at the Citadel when asked about
traveling to ilo's alone with the help
from the council Ambassador udina ends
up grounding the ship which stops us
from leaving I never understood this
Mission it's a nice way to get the
player to explore the Citadel and find
new side missions but given the urgency
of the task ahead it's a very normal
reaction to want to leave as soon as
possible the problem is that this should
not be an easy task all we do is talk to
Anderson and devise a plan which is that
he's going to knock out udina and unlock
our restraints allowing us to leave from
the council meeting to leaving the
Citadel this entire Mission lasts
literally 10 minutes grounding the
Normandy sounded like defeat that we are
now truly stuck and can't stop sarin but
the fact that it was able to be undone
this quickly loses all the dramatic
tension it was supposed to have I think
the reason that it lost all that
dramatic tension was because they were
saving it for one of Joker's best lines
in the entire game when the crew gets
close to ilos they realize that landing
near saren won't be as easy as they
thought and while the whole crew is
bickering at one another trying to find
a solution Joker speaks up and becomes
the voice of reason the group needed I
find another Landing Zone there is no
other Landing Zone The Descent angle's
too steep it's our only option
it's not an option it's a suicide run we
don't I can do it
Joker I can do it
I can't even be mad at this because he
actually did manage to pull it off
Shepard lands on ilos and needs to get
inside this bunker so that he can find
sarin there is dozens of Geth in between
us and the path ahead but after some
time Shepard manages to unlock the
bunker but ends up getting blocked by
some barrier this isn't some Ambush
though as vigil here did this so that we
could meet with him vigil is a prothean
VI and he'll give us more information
about the protheans and the Reapers ilos
was used as a secret research base and
the group stationed here was spared from
the extinction because the records of
iOS were white when the Reapers attacked
the Citadel Virgil was created to make
sure the facility was running smoothly
but also to make sure there was some way
to wake up the remaining protheans once
they went into a cryogenic slumber
vigils succeeded in doing this but he
had not predicted that the extinction of
the protheans would last as long as it
did to conserve power he had to kill off
the protheans in cryosleep one by one to
make sure the facility stayed on he only
managed to save 12 of the top
researchers before he was able to fully
wake them up this was not the outcome
the protheans had once did but despite
this setback they managed to gain an
upper hand on the Reapers and it has to
do with the keepers throughout Mass
Effect 1 you'll come across these
bizarre creatures that just sit and do
whatever it is that they're doing no one
knows what they are doing or why but
it's common law not to disturb them
however they serve a much greater
purpose the asari weren't technically
the first race to make it into the
council it was the keepers but because
they were a little more than servants
they just spent most of their life
making sure the Citadel was ready for
when the next species arrived as we know
from our talk with Sovereign The Citadel
was created by the Reapers to help them
Aid life down a path of evolution and
the Keepers were going to be a key
component of this plan the keepers are
hypothesized to be one of if not the
first race the Reapers conquered and
it's likely because of this that they
were used as servants and not killed off
like the following species after the
genocide of the Galaxy took place a
Reaper would stay behind to monitor the
next civilization's progress in the
current time Sovereign was the one to
stay behind after that one Reaper deemed
it was time they would then activate a
signal which would compel the keepers to
activate the Citadel relay which linked
into dark space so the Citadel isn't
just some large structure that people
can live on it's a giant mass relay this
dark Space by the way is where the
reapers are known to live it's unknown
where this dark space is or what it
looks like but it's assumed to be a
place with little tin of light just like
in Mass Effect a lot of our knowledge of
space is within the Milky Way galaxy the
closest large galaxy to the Milky Way is
called the Andromeda galaxy which is why
the recent game is called Andromeda but
it's roughly 4 billion light years away
in between this is just black for the
most part the Reapers likely live in
that dark space outside the Milky Way
galaxy the issue though is that the
Reapers can't use this signal anymore
those 12 prothean researchers use what
they call the conduit to achieve this
the conduit is a mini Mass relay and was
created by the protheans when they were
first experimenting with mass relay
technology this is basically a back door
to the Citadel the protheans use this
relay to go back to the Citadel after
the Reapers left so they could change
the signal on the keepers this worked
but the relay was only one way so they
likely starved and died on on the
Citadel shortly after this is why saren
wants the conduit as it's going to allow
him to bypass the citadel's external
defenses allowing him and his Geth Army
to attack from the inside he will then
eventually transfer over control to
Sovereign which will allow Sovereign to
override all the Citadel systems
manually open the relay letting all the
other Reapers inside and by the time
Shepard makes it to the Citadel most of
this plan had already been complete
sarin had blocked the arms of the
Citadel so that no one could enter
allowing Sovereign to override the
systems in peace Shepard manages to
battle his way to sarin but something is
different about him saren says that he
has improved and that Sovereign has
implanted him seren began to grow
doubtful about sovereign's plan thanks
to Shepherd's words on vermeier
Sovereign census and indoctrinated siren
so that he no longer feels conflicted
Shepard however can still get through to
him with his words and disappointed in
what he's become will kill himself
before Sovereign can take him over
Shepard then takes back control of the
Citadel systems and now has to choose
what to do should he tell the alliance
to focus on Sovereign or save the
council in all my playthroughs I've
always picked to save them it makes no
sense not to not only does the council
dying leave all the species in the
Galaxy without a leader but the destiny
Ascension the ship thereon not only
holds another 10 000 people but is
massive and probably the deadliest ship
in the Galaxy Sovereign ends up being
defeated regardless of what you choose
which is why this decision is such a
no-brainer to me if Sovereign had the
chance to survive if we saved the
console then that would have been a
rather interesting development but this
would likely cause complications with
the main story so that probably wouldn't
have worked but Shepard isn't finished
with his job yet sarin is still alive
but now completely morphed into this
synthetic machine which are likely the
implants that he was talking about
earlier I don't know if I'm alone in
this feeling but I've always felt bad
for saren he was face to face with an
enemy that he knew could not be defeated
and realized how insignificant life was
in the Galaxy he then became brainwashed
over the course of the game and is still
trying to convince himself that he is
real and what he is thinking is real but
that is slowly being taken away from him
the more time he spends with Sovereign
this all Bridge is a boiling point at
the very end of the game where for a
brief moment he realizes that he was
wrong and that his plan wasn't going to
save Humanity so he decides to take his
own life now though we can probably
start being honest with ourselves
Sharon's not the greatest person he
killed people like Nyla simply because
they got in his way he despises humans
like most durians who fought in the
first Contact Wars and according to
Anderson when the two were stationed
together on a mission saren killed
various innocent people he embodies the
ends justify the means kind of ideology
it's also possible to not convince saren
at the end if your Paragon or Renegade
isn't high enough which means that him
killing himself is not guaranteed to
happen the best part about saren though
is that you can completely disagree with
me I find him incredibly well written
because he's not an evil for the sake of
being evil kind of antagonist he had a
real genuine reason for doing what he
did but the ways he went about doing
that very thing was not how it should
have been handled serum's attitude
towards the player can shape their
Outlook of him which can pretty much be
said for all the other decisions in the
game like the rachni queen and the
council's Fate all these beings will
change the opinion of the player but not
all people who played this game will
come to the same conclusion and that not
only makes a great story but a great RPG
after the defeat of saren for real this
time Sovereign gets taken down and the
council's Fate is left up to the
player's decision but also left up to
the player's decision is the first human
counselor and it's surprisingly
difficult to choose the choice is
between udina and Anderson houdin has
been a prick to us since the beginning
and Anderson has always had our back but
udina is a politician this is his realm
but is that who we really want on the
council personally I've always found
myself choosing Anderson with the hope
that even though he may not be cut off
for the job he'll at least have
Humanity's best interests at heart but
if our own world is anything to look at
you can't really get far by being nice
fighting fire with fire is necessary in
politics and udina is our fire but
humans are already looked down upon by
the rest of the Galaxy as is When udina
likely confirmed the stereotypes that
have been put onto Humanity already a
bunch of colonizing [ __ ] pushing
all their freedoms and ideas onto these
other races like they own the place
it's hard to say it's the beauty of a
choice though you won't know what the
outcome is until you do it but by now
you may be wondering when the choices
are actually going to start coming back
up and this is a fair criticism Mass
Effect has five main choices the fates
of the rack night Queen Ashley and Kaden
Rex the council and the next counselor
the only ones we get to see are the
outcomes of our companions but they
don't have many major effects on the
story unless you accidentally got Rex
killed or liked both Ashley and Kaden if
you were content with your decision then
you likely didn't have them in your
party anyway I said that I would pick
Caden over Ashley and this is still true
but I would toss both off a cliff if I
had to choose between them or the other
companions if you didn't like Rex Ashley
or Caden and you just chose for them to
die then that's not really a heavy
hitting decision because even if they
lived you probably wouldn't have put
them in your fire team anyway the other
decisions besides these two don't see
the light of day we don't see the
consequences of these actions until the
sequels and it's here where the
criticism can be split messavix is
really meant to be a Trilogy a
three-game experience variants played
back to back or at the very least with
the same save files that you can
continue your story the outcomes of
these decisions will have some
consequences just not here in Mass
Effect 1. so as a singular game Mass
Effect 1 does provide different choices
and potential outcomes but for the most
part none of those really matter many of
the quests in the game can still be
completed it's just if you want to say
good or bad things during dialogue both
playthroughs ended up with little
differences one's just missing a Krogan
a queen and an entire Council and while
that may be seen is a huge difference we
don't see much of the ramifications of
these actions but I feel like it's
unfair to judge a game that was
intentionally made to be a continuous
multi-game experience so while we don't
get to see the fruits of our labor now I
am glad we get to see them eventually
but how important these decisions really
end up being will have to be discussed
in the future when we find them still
more important than the decisions is the
story surrounding them Mass Effect 1 is
an excellent game it may have started
slow but it was necessary as it needed
to set the groundwork for what's to come
it was able to provide the player with a
plethora of details both in-game via
conversation and out of game by a codex
about the world races and history that
are at the core of this series it
creates unique companions that all have
their own thoughts and opinions that are
centered around their own racist history
and how that specific history has
changed their perception of the Galaxy
it also perfectly showcased the game's
main threat in a way that forces the
player to come to terms with what the
hell they just saw Sovereign in the
Reapers trivializes the player's own
mediocre existence within the game world
there's always a bigger fish as they say
this fish just happened to wipe out the
Galaxy when every species was at its
apex for millions of years it'd be
different if the Reapers just wiped out
species whenever they wanted but they're
waiting for them to be at their Peak to
do so it's like a warrior refusing to
fight his opponent because they aren't
strong enough and then waiting until
they are stronger and more on their
level so that they can have a good fight
knowing that no matter how strong that
person becomes they're still going to
win and the fact that the reapers are
the personification of that idea is a
frightening realization and it's only
going to get worse from here
thank you all for watching today and I
hope you enjoyed if you did be sure to
like And subscribe as we still have many
more games and many more Mass Effect
games to cover here on the channel
apologies for taking a bit longer than
usual to get this video out I explained
a bit more of why in the recent
Community post but hopefully it won't
happen again as always thank you to my
returning viewers for coming back to
another video and with that take care
everyone
goodbye